like if somebody says something i don't
like
um
good afternoon
welcome to uh the faculty roundtable
portion
of this week's cca and again this is the
the third cca if you're keeping track
third cc
a of the 2014-2015 academic year
uh and obviously this one has been on
american journalism
my name is mark nussbaum i'm a chair of
the chemistry department but also
more to the point dean of faculty here
at hillsdale college
and i have the opportunity to introduce
the roundtable
members and also give a few of my own
thoughts and then we'll
we'll turn it over to them so
again the purpose of this session is
provide an opportunity for all of us to
reflect on
things that we've learned things that
we've thought about this week
as we've listened to the cca speakers
and just pick up some key points
questions of interest
et cetera so the topic of the cca again
obviously has been american journalism
and some of its key players
and i just wanted to briefly mention my
brother
uh he's he's not a quote key player but
he's been a journalist for a number of
years
basically all of his career at the
philadelphia inquirer newspaper
and um i'm obviously not a journalist
i'm a chemist but occasionally i'll have
opportunity to
have conversation with my brother about
this state of american journalism
and so we have those conversations every
once in a while and
and obviously probably obviously more to
the the students here than anybody else
technology
and social media have really altered the
landscape
for journalism in america and
the newspaper business especially is in
a bad way
deeply deeply affected by what's been
going on in terms of
internet and facebook and all the online
blogs and chats customers don't want to
pay
for what they view as a clumsy and slow
hard copy of something that they see as
being available free
online so my brother uh
newspaperman that he is even riley jokes
that
the fact that his 21 year old son is
looking for a newspaper job
is evidence of quote a failure in
parenting
he feels so he's not you know looking at
the prospects for for newspaper
journalism jobs as being
all that wonderful right now so
professional print journalism
is in a time of drastic change evolve or
die
you might say similarly television and
radio journalism
are having to adjust rapidly as well to
the explosion of channels and electronic
media and yet the level of of accuracy
and professionalism and editorial review
of online and electronic materials um
vary greatly
so how do we as customers ensure that
the new sources that we rely on
are reliable
clearly i'm no expert nor even a
well-studied amateur on
the topic but that's the point of this
whole
session for you and me people
who are just listeners and hoping to be
lifelong learners to think about
and express some of our questions some
of our thoughts
about this issue so the ccas serve to
shine light in an area that we might not
otherwise
study or find ourselves to be experts in
so basically this roundtable session
is for you and the audience and for us
as well on the round table to
discuss to learn from one another and
from things that we've picked up
and thought about through the week now
although i'm not an expert i should be
fair there are others on this roundtable
especially john miller who are indeed
experts in the field so i don't mean to
denigrate their expertise
but still for all of us we are all
learners we all have room to grow and to
learn
and to develop so while the roundtable
members are
to some extent here to teach it's
probably more accurate to see the round
table as an opportunity
to share what we are learning and
thinking about in light of what we've
seen and heard this week
for the stake sake of stimulating one
another to stimulating all of us to
deeper understanding
in light of that purpose we want to hear
not only from the roundtable members but
also from you so there will be a q a
session at the end of this
towards the latter part of the of the
hour and then we'll finish up at five
o'clock
so i'll introduce the faculty panelists
now and each of them
will spend five to ten minutes um
giving their reflections on the cca and
then i'll open the floor to
questions and answers so we'll we'll go
in order
here after the introductions so uh the
first uh person that you see to my right
your left is is dr peter blum
he's the director of our sociology and
social thought program
here at hillsdale and also professor of
philosophy and culture
he's been at hillsdale since 1992. pete
earned his ba from goshen college
and his ma in philosophy and his phd in
sociology
from notre dame he also also served as
an adjunct at indiana university and is
at spring and at spring arbor
university then we have dr matthew young
he's an associate professor of chemistry
who's been here since 2007.
he earned his bachelor's degree from
seattle pacific university
and his phd from northwestern in 2007.
he also serves as a science education
consultant for the hillsdale
barney charter school initiative
then mr john miller grew up in detroit
but now lives
out in the uh sticks of hillsdale county
uh along a dirt road so he's gone from
the big city to the big
outback if you will of hillsdale county
he's the director
of the dow journalism program here at
hillsdale
and he writes for the national review
for the wall street journal and many
other publications
john is the author of five books
including the first assassin
a historical thriller set during the
civil war and the big scrum
how teddy roosevelt saved football the
chronicle of higher education has called
him
one of the best literary journalists in
the country to learn more about john
miller and his journalistic endeavors
visit his website
if you're interested at
www.haymiller.com
so we'll proceed in that order with uh
remarks from each so
dr blum
thank you very much i'd like to thank
the organizers for another informative
and thought-provoking cca this week
and dr nussbaum for asking me to be a
part of this
round table
in hearing from me you hear from someone
whose conservatism if there is such a
thing
is the stripe of conservatism that's not
so much a position
on a political spectrum but more of
an antipathy toward the toward and
distrust of the very idea of political
positions
for those who want a name to be dropped
i think this puts me in
burke's line in the general neighborhood
that russell kirk
considered his home and maybe on the
side of town nearest old michael
oakshott's place now
to be clear notice that i don't mean to
question the existence
or on some level even the practical
necessity
of political positions stands must be
taken
decisions must be made and evil must not
be allowed to flourish
through good people doing nothing
but i see little danger in this room
this week that we will miss the
importance of speaking
plainly seeing what simply is the case
and acting courageously
my tendency is to thank taking a cue
from
of all people michel foucault that
everything
is dangerous now foucault
as some of you might know was no
political conservative
he identified himself often in practice
with the european
political left but as i and some other
people
have tried to point out elsewhere it's
quite misleading to see foucault's work
as ideologically left
and it's it is a valuable resource for
insights that may be
just as friendly to a conservative
temperament
as his critics who identify themselves
as leftists have often noticed
from foucault i've picked up a tendency
to look
always for danger
even in the ways that we look for and
try to work against
danger i have long understood this
tendency to be
entirely consistent with my admiration
for
kirk who seems about as often to have
puzzled
and disconcerted other conservatives as
he has given them
genuine insight and inspiration you
should
watch for bradley burzer's biography of
kirk
which is forthcoming i understand from
the university press of kentucky
now such a conservative orientation if
it's left to itself
seems to keep making things difficult
and complex when others
really would like to keep it simple and
do what needs to be done
i myself am quite bad at allowing things
to be simple i'm pretty good at making
things more difficult and complex
i hope you know that's not necessarily
the requirement to be a good professor
but i happen to be good at it but i need
those of you who tend to lose
patience with that kind of complexity
and i realized that if it were only up
to me probably nothing would get done
and a lot of evil would flourish
but right now at this moment in this
place
i've been given my ten minutes and while
i do want to applaud
the desire for simple clarity and
resolute action
i will briefly indulge my determined
delight
in difficulty so bear with me
my concern is with how we must deal with
the common
oversimplification involved in the
contrast
between conservatives that's us
and liberals that's them if you're
taking notes
this simplified schema has hovered over
the entire week
though i think it's fair to say that it
was especially overt in
hugh hewitt's lecture on talk radio
the fact that it is an
oversimplification is something
all of us know i suspect
i don't need to act as though i'm
identifying it
even in this particular context and even
more often
in the q and a session it's always been
there
sometimes explicitly but i can't help
myself
i'm sorry i have to do a bit of
underlining
i especially felt my complexity complex
beginning to boil at the idea of
quantifying
and measuring a precise level of
conservatism
like taking someone's temperature on a
specified scale
fahrenheit or celsius now it can be very
helpful to quantify and measure
all kinds of things don't get me wrong
and i do not mean to suggest that tim
gross closest study is without
significant work
worth but i see a danger
remember that word danger in remembering
and promulgating
the quantitative characterization of the
influence of media bias that he provided
but forgetting or at least minimizing
some of what we heard in the q a
regarding the dimensions of the matter
at hand
that had to be omitted or ignored
for sound methodological reasons or
refraining from mentioning
that the level of confidence in the
measurement's precision
is not as high as one would like
or to me the most striking point from
that discussion
how the margin for error might be wide
enough to pull the result
pretty far toward educated guess
territory despite the scientific
clothing that it wears
i think the more important place to
point to though
if it's complexity that i'm after is
last night's talk on menken
by fred siegel i think that
there is where we heard the most overt
willingness
to own the complications that can be
covered over
by the simplified schema i'm not in a
position
to give any decisive judgment on sigel's
historical claims
about menkin's influence though they are
consistent
with my amateur impressions the ones i
already had
what i would especially urge you to
notice explicitly
is how he cast his argument conceptually
the distinction between political
liberalism
and cultural liberalism that he supposed
though it was not what he was centrally
concerned with
in arguing it was deployed for us in
such a way
i'd suggest that it was to a substantial
degree
motivated you might say by how it made
sense of
menkin's influence across
superficially ideological lines
conservatives who are familiar with how
cultural conservatism which itself has
multiple streams
is not always a comfortable companion of
political conservatism
also having more than one stream that's
something
we know about i'm afraid that there is
danger
in not remembering that the same is true
broadly speaking
of what we call liberalism
that's i think part of what his talk
reminded us of the complication
gets worse of course along the path that
i'm pointing out here
my view for example is that being
conservative
and being liberal and some widely
accepted uses of
those terms are completely compatible
regarding such problems of demarcation
and differentiation
i recommend that you read an essay by
the polish philosopher
leshek kolakowski
the essay is called how to be a
conservative liberal
socialist it's a wonderful little essay
it's only a couple of pages long but it
packs a powerful punch
as most all of kolakowski's writings do
for those of you who don't know
kolakowski was
originally a marxist and he wrote
at the time that he was actually moving
away from marxism
rejecting it he wrote a three-volume
study
of the history of marxism that's still
as far as i know is one of
uh the sort of magisterial studies of
the history of marxism
um he his writings since that time
should be of a lot of interest
to cultural conservatives
now i might be closing in on the end of
my time limit
do i intend to invalidate the simplified
schema
that mr hewitt so artfully employed
no do i intend to suggest that anyone
here is wrong
to think that hillsdale's journalism
program under john miller's capable
leadership
should not be applauded for aspiring to
correct the imbalance that worries
us all so much by no means
do i intend to suggest that the dangers
we all want to address
forthrightly and passionately are not
real dangers absolutely not
so what's your point blum
friedrich nietzsche said that if one
fights monsters
one must take care that one does not
also become
a monster among other things
this suggests the need to take care in
defining what is
and what is not a monster
and perhaps the need to take care in
defining the extent
to which what we are fighting
or better the extent to which who
we are fighting is a monster
let us remember that i'm fairly certain
that our excellent journalism program
in partnership with our liberal arts
corps
does cultivate the remembrance of that
as we cheer for our side in what is
often painted
as a battle against monsters let us all
help to make sure that it stays that way
thank you for listening
good afternoon over the past three days
we have heard interesting and
wide-ranging
discussion on journalism we've heard
about journalism in the founding era
the resistance of government to
transparency for journalists
metrics of of the influence of
journalists on the people
important characteristics that
conservative journalists have
the importance of the first amendment in
the history of journalism
and the influences behind the
development of cultural liberalism in
america
through these talks one thing that we've
clearly seen is that
journalism has been and continues to be
very important in shaping
society and that's no surprise his
primary way we get information
and opinion on what's happening in the
world
i like dr nussbaum pointed out i'm of
course not a journalist
and i don't have any particular
expertise in journalism
um and in fact i should give a
disclaimer not only that i
am not what you would consider a news
junkie and i should admit i don't
consume as much good journalism as i
probably should
my interest in journalism is simply the
basic idea that i want to know what's
happening in the world
and what it means and so in the next few
minutes i simply want to
offer a few basic thoughts on the talks
that we've heard over the last
three days uh the first observation that
i'd like to make
is the connection between the great
power of journalism
and the virtue of journalists
in the opening talk of the cca mr
brookheiser
illustrated four different aspects of
journalists
by giving us examples from the founding
era of america
these aspects or characteristics of
journalists
that he discussed were attacking amusing
instructing and inspiring and he gave
anecdotes illustrating
each of these aspects in historical
figures and we saw that each of the
figures had a
large influence through their writing
we saw that dr grossklose argued that it
can be measured
that the media leans to the left of
center on average
as measured by the pq or the political
quotient of the people
via questionnaire about bills that have
been before congress
and the sq or the slant quotient of the
media which was a metric he developed
based on
references to various think tanks by
newspapers
and the main idea there was that media
bias has an effect on the pq of the
people
which he measured through this media
lambda which was based on
three studies that were some something
like experiments on
how people respond to the media that
they consume
the numerical values he gave didn't seem
very meaningful
because of the high uncertainties but
the overall point that the media can
have an
impact on the political views of the
people is compelling
also in the talk last night we heard how
the writing of h.l mencken had a
tremendous impact on the american left
and so we see that journalism can do
great things and journalism can do not
so great things
i thought this was especially
interesting in this area of
the attack aspect of journalism and i
think it raises the question can
the attack aspect be done well
the examples that were given were
well written but they were not done well
in the sense that i
that i have in mind however i do think
that
um
i think i think that it can but i think
that it's a fine line to
to walk uh mr brookheiser mentioned in
the q a
he said quote there is something
disreputable about journalism
end quote almost like there is an
unavoidable
seedy side to the enterprise he said
that journalists tell things that people
don't want known
but this can be important
additionally mr brookheiser discussed
hamilton raising the question
can societies establish good government
through reflection and choice
and he went on through his papers to uh
answer that question and so that that
question has been answered
um but now but we can consider that
question because it's now up to us
to recover and to maintain good
government through reflection and choice
this of course is done in part by
reading information and thoughtful
arguments
and reflecting on them and then making
informed choices
so how can journalists implement these
four aspects of
journalism well in our day it seems to
me that the answer comes from the
primary themes of mr hewitt's talk
he talked about rectitude which he
defined as virtue supported by external
bearing
when he was talking about conservatives
in talk radio
he made the claim that their success was
due to
the fact that one they know what they're
talking about
and two they are authentically what they
say they are
additionally he had five challenges for
young journalists
the first was to be good to be people of
virtue
the second was to be gracious here he
talked about modeling
a thoughtful conversation with liberals
on his show
which was one of my favorite comments um
that he made
it seems to me there's there's so much
shouting and name calling
and ripping a part of straw men that
goes on and
one of the greatest skills that one can
develop is the ability to engage in
interesting
and respectful dialogue with someone
that you disagree with
the third thing that he uh the third
challenge that he gave was to be
grateful for opportunities
um that you have and remember who has
helped you along the way
uh the fourth was to work hard and this
kind of kind of reminded me that all
journalists all excellent journalism is
the product of of hard work
and in fact in mr brookheiser's talk he
observed that
journalism can do great things but
journalists don't always have good lives
when he talked about the end of the
lives of his four examples
um and and
that reminded me that good journalism is
an important service to the society
i i would think that that it would or at
least could be fulfilling work but it's
also hard work
long hours requiring sacrifice
and i think this is true whether your
subject is sports
developments in science developments in
politics
or something else uh the fifth
challenge that mr hewitt gave for young
journalists was to actually believe in
the importance of what you're doing
he he phrased it as if we lose america
loses
and by we i think he means
conservative journalists or maybe
conservatives in general
and so these characteristics that mr
hewitt laid out for journalists
allow the four aspects of journalism for
mr brookhiser
to be done in a way that points toward
what is good and what is true
they even allow for the attack aspect
which i
take to mean uncovering impropriety
uh to be done without malice or without
an intent to mislead
and so in short what we need is men and
women in journalism who are good
decent well-educated and have integrity
and in fact we need people like this in
all fields of study and this is what
we're about
at hillsdale just a couple of other
comments
if we go back to this idea of being
gracious one of the striking themes i
thought
last night regarding menken was his
disdain for the people
in fact he this the speaker mentioned a
couple of times this this
phrase that menken had the the bubuaji
uh referring to the middle class um
and we've heard in a couple of the talks
that this is something that
persists in liberal ideology the idea
this idea that people are too stupid to
know
what they need or to know what they want
or should want from their leaders
and and we should reject this and we
should demand that we should demand
journalism
that shows respect for its audience and
of course
leaders who show respect for the people
we heard in this kind of what dr
nussbaum alluded to in his intro we
heard
several mentions but not a lot of
discussion of
facebook and twitter and how important
they are or how important they'll be in
the future
um i am speaking in almost complete
ignorance
on this but i i thought it was
interesting and i don't know how
important they will be in the long term
or how useful they will be
but i did want to say in the short term
i would encourage students to
not rely too heavily on those as your
sources for good writing
maybe they're useful in other ways but
uh just because
we have twitter doesn't mean that we
have to all be on twitter
all of the time and more generally i
encourage you students to seek
thoughtful information from a variety of
sources
and not to just seek your own opinion
when you're reading
reading about reflections on what's
happening in the world
looking only for your own opinion being
reflected back to you
i think reading different viewpoints can
broaden your understanding and sharpen
your thinking
i think we've heard throughout the three
days of some of the excellent writing at
the wall street journal
national review the telecasts on on fox
news
and of course conservative talk radio i
would encourage
uh to you to add to that uh
well as as just a couple of examples
lots of great things out there but
to add to that the thoughtful commentary
an interesting discussion that can be
found on the atlantic
or npr it won't hurt anything
thank you
a few months ago gallup the polling
company
put out a survey you can look up online
and the headline of his press release
says it all
trust in mass media returns to all-time
low it said that
measured americans trust in the media
it found that only as it reported only
40 percent have a
a great deal or a fair amount of trust
in the media the better way to put it
the journalistic way to put it i think
would be
60 percent have not very much or no
trust at all
in the media that's an all-time low
one of the curiosities when you look at
longitudinally when you look at this um
trust in the media tends to dip during
election years
and then it goes up in non-election
years and so when you when you see the
graph you're
they ask this question every year when
you look at the graph it looks like the
blade of a saw kind of turned upside
down you know peaks and valleys peaks
and valleys
so uh we'll probably have a little more
trust in the media this year but it's
but there is a there's a long term down
downward trend
and a lot of reasons why that's probably
true uh many of them having to do with
journalism i think a few of them
actually having to do with
with larger questions but uh
there you go and this this this survey
brought to mind for me a comment rick
brookheiser made in the first lecture
the cca and as a comment matt just just
just referred to himself
a moment ago which is there's there's
something a little disreputable
about journalists in journalism
something a little bit
disreputable and i think he i think
there's a lot of truth in what he says
but i'm going to push back against that
claim a little bit and then
in the process of of pushing back
against that claim i hope maybe maybe
tease out a few themes
from the last uh three days of this cca
and uh um um
with some very different speakers and
topics and so forth maybe find some
things that that bring them all together
so is journalism disreputable well maybe
now here at hillsdale college we uh we
make a big deal of statesmanship
right our great we have a graduate
school of statesmanship
we have a campus dotted with statues of
statesmen
well we know statesmanship is a high and
noble calling these are good things to
study and emulate and learn about and so
on and so forth we also know there are
plenty of crooked politicians in the
world
in fact the front page of today's new
york post
the newspaper founded by alexander
hamilton the front page of today's new
york post the top story is not
the mountains of snow that kept brett
stevens from joining us here this week
it's about the leader of the state
senate resigning
in a corruption scandal an alleged
corruption scandal one of the most
powerful
a sort of a legendarily powerful man in
new york state politics resigning
so he may not be a statesman
he's a democrat but it's not just
democrats who are this way a month ago a
republican congressman resigned because
he's been convicted or
uh indicted in tax fraud michael grimm
resigned his uh his seat in congress
so there are crooked politicians or
allegedly politicians in in in
in in both parties we know that
and yet we still look for statesmen
when we think about 2016 who's going to
run for president who's going to win
we all do it with an eye toward hoping
maybe a statesman will emerge
and do something good for this country
so there are crooked politicians but
we're always looking for statesmen too
and we can look for great journalism and
we know how much we need it
president erin said something on this
stage yesterday
it's kind of obvious although it never
occurred to me
freedom of the press is in the first
amendment
the first amendment has a kind of pride
a place doesn't it
it's not a randomly assigned amendment
it's not the fifth amend the seventh
amendment
it's the first amendment and some of her
most important freedoms are in that
amendment he explained why
well that's where you find freedom of
the press and that's how important the
press is
in journalism is to a free society
now when we define journalism a lot of
ways we can divine journalism a kind of
popular way of doing this saying
journalism is history's first
rough draft right journalists write the
rough draft of history
someone take that and say well yeah a
different way of looking at someone
someone said
you know learning about a more
pejorative way learning about our world
through journalism is like trying to
tell the time by looking at the second
hand on a clock
right first draft of history look at you
know how much can you really interpret
from that there's sometimes a tendency
not to take journalism seriously
it's ephemeral it's forgettable it's
fish wrap by friday
you know i know that's what you guys do
with your collegians on friday
use it for cat litter you know fish wrap
by friday we say have newspapers
there can be a tendency not to take it
seriously
but the great journalism is something
more brett stevens couldn't join us of
course but he had
his column appeared in the wall street
journal yesterday
i don't know who saw it it's a great
column as so many of his are it's on the
election that just took place in greece
he explained what happened he
interpreted a force he's very smart but
it's about more than that too
if you read deeply and it's only seven
or eight hundred words long but it's
also about the nature of capitalism
the importance of capitalism is about is
about corruption so
many many things and at the end it was
just telling us what to make of this
election in greece what it means for the
eu
what it means for global finances and on
and on and on
in 800 words he did an awful lot
in my classrooms when i define
journalism i like to call it the
literature of what just happened
and i also like to place emphasis on the
word literature
now not every piece of journalism in
fact the overwhelming majority of it is
not
what we would call great literature it's
just stuff we want to read informs of
us about our world but we know it can be
great literature and rick brookheiser
reminded
us us of this on sunday when he quoted
tom paine
these are the times that try men's souls
he said and he read that whole paragraph
that whole first paragraph of the
american crisis and he said something
really struck me i never thought of it
before
it's a paragraph i've told my students
to read over and over again in fact i've
made some of them memorize it
for midterms it's a great paragraph
he said it's shakespearean remember that
he said it reminds him of the saint
crispin's day speech in henry v
now that's some pretty high praise tom
payne playing on the same field as
william
shakespeare he also went on to say we
couldn't sustain it right i wouldn't say
pain is the equal of shakespeare but
my what a great moment he had with that
paragraph
you could also see it was churchillian
that paragraph a kind of fighting spirit
behind it
at a critical moment but it was
journalism
and so when we hear people talk about
mere journalists or mere journalism
i think of a line by a music critic a
british music critic named ernest newman
and he said
journalist is a term of contempt
employed by writers who are not read
about writers who are
now you guys uh uh most of you are
students you've been walking around
campus uh
all school year and you've probably seen
these posters we put up for the
collegian
with these with these famous people
pointing out that they're journalists
right
yes we've seen these things you know
reagan churchill orwell twain
all journalists right
and you know what it is kind of a
recruitment poster for the collegian
just trying to persuade some of you guys
to come out and write for the collegian
a little bit do some good work
good work there but but
the the fundamental point is what i'm
trying to make here which is which is
great literature can come out of
journalism
some of the best things that have been
thought and said have been done through
journalism
and i can go on and on and on with
examples i could tell you we have eight
of those posters up now there are more
coming
we're gonna keep doing this series
i'm gonna read you uh three more that i
planned soon
milton was a journalist before he wrote
paradise lost
john milton wrote political pamphlets on
free speech and divorce
swift was a journalist before he wrote
gulliver's travels in a modest proposal
jonathan swift was the editor
of a touring newspaper in london
publius was a journalist before the
federalist papers were bound up in books
they were published as op-eds in 18th
century newspapers so we think of some
of these writers milton swift publius
and so forth we think of our norton
anthology of literature
or the federalist papers in your uh the
reader they they made the constitution
reader they make you guys
read they don't look like journalism
when you get them that way but they
really are the products of journalism
and they are great journalism they're
the kind of journalism we should hope to
have more of them can you imagine a
world without these
writers without these works it's
unimaginable
these kinds of journalists help us see
the whole clock
not just the second hand that's the very
best kind of journalism
general observation about some of the
some of the
topics which could on first glance see
kind of scattered and all over the place
when we when we look at the problems of
journalism the the challenges of
journalism
we see the problems of today are the
problems of yesterday
some people say the past is a foreign
country the idea being when you look at
the passage is so hard to interpret it's
like going to a foreign land you can't
possibly understand it's an alien
culture the past is a foreign country
people say
but sometimes when you look at the past
really close you get a sense of deja vu
and remind you of the world we inhabit
right now in fact it seems it seems
incredibly familiar
because they fight about the same things
we fight about right now
john milton when he was a political
pamphleteer
was talking about divorce
or he's talking about the ingredients of
a free society the need for free press
we fight about these things right now
jonathan swift in a modest proposal
was dealing with the problem of the poor
what do we do about the poor
that's a problem will never go away
and publius of course dealing with the
nature of government what kind of
government do we want
we fight about that now too the fights
are the same
in so many cases now their influence is
always in dispute
we had a lecture last night on h.l
menken as a kind of a kind of
founding father of of modern liberalism
uh we look at a figure like james
calendar he's the
the muckraking journalist from the
founding era that rick brookheiser
talked about
remember he's the guy who broke the news
of alexander hamilton's adultery
and thomas jefferson's purported
relationship with the slave
sally hemings are we glad he did those
things
does private morality influence public
character
those are questions they were dealing
with right then we deal with them right
now all the time
with our public figures does their
private behavior matter in terms of
their public character should we draw
lines between them or not it's the same
thing
cheryl ackerson seems to me like a
reporter doesn't have a political bone
in her body
remember she resisted i think some
people asked her questions you know sort
of baited her to come out and say you
know right wingy kinds of things you
know
opportunities to give the hillsdale
crowd what it wants to hear and she
completely resisted that didn't she
does that make her an ideal reporter an
ideal
and certain and and um ideally objective
well maybe makes a good one i think we
want all kinds of reporters
i like tim gross closest presentation on
media bias
i like pete a little bit i'm a little
skeptical of the numbers you know
numbers frighten and confuse me just as
a general rule but
um uh i think tim is right on the big
question i'm not quite sure he proved it
right you ever do a mat your math
problems are saying you know show your
proof
you know sometimes you get the you get
the answer right but you can't show your
proof
i had a little sense of that um um tim's
a smart guy though and i think there's i
think i think he's on to something
but i share some of pete's uh
reservations at the same time
is talk radio a medium of partisan
slumbers
you know we hear that kind of accusation
all the time or does a guy like you he
would actually elevate the kind of
conversation and educate us and make us
better citizens when we listen to him
and so on and so forth i'm going to
close with uh
line from tocqueville another guy you
guys can't
escape hillsdale without reading a
little bit of him
he's a big thick book on democracy in
america of course spent some time over
here
in fact if de tocqueville is alive today
he might not have written a big book i
think when he traveled through america
he might have blogged his way through
america with his observations right
that maybe is what he would have done
today but he wrote his book back then we
study it now
tocqueville understood the importance of
newspapers in a free press
in the united states he understood how
it contributes to civil society
how we need it for discourse how to
communicate with each other and why
every informed citizen needs to read
newspapers he was talking about
newspapers because that's what they were
back then
but needs to stay informed through
journalism is how you might put it more
generally he said this of newspapers
we should underrate their importance if
we thought they just guaranteed liberty
they maintain
civilization he said
they maintain civilization they
certainly maintain our american
civilization i think so
i hope you've enjoyed the cca this week
and i think we'll take questions
thank you john and each of the panelists
um so now we would like to open it up
for
questions uh from the audience and so
there are a couple of our
students with microphones so as has been
the case throughout the week if you have
a question please raise your hand and
wait for
the person to come with a microphone and
then if you could go ahead and stand up
and give your question or comment and
you can direct those questions uh
comments to the panel as a whole or if
you have a specific person in mind that
you'd like to address it to just go
ahead and
and do so so floor is open and again
we'll uh we'll wrap it up around five
o'clock
okay um my question has to do with uh
dr arn and mr hewitt's discussion
yesterday
about snowden
more so because i was thinking about
like if we think back to woodward and
bernstein
and deep throat and what he did i mean
it's obviously a different situation
it's like nationals
but it's still a national secret and it
was still someone inside the government
that knew that
something he morally thought was going
wrong and then leaked it to a newspaper
to spread that information
so is there like any correlation there
and how should that inform
how to be a good journalist like was
what deep throat did wrong
and what woodward and bernstein did
wrong the same way that we're saying
what snowden and the new york times did
was wrong
i do think they're they're different
cases uh woodward and bernstein for
we're
we're not dealing with with national
security secrets for for
for one thing a better example from that
arrow be the pentagon papers
uh during during the vietnam war if you
want kind of a closer parallel
um i'll say this you know i just made
the point that that that the fights of
yesterday the fights of today
uh the these these are the sorts of
tensions we're dealing with all the time
in my in my history journalism class
which you should take natalie the uh the
first thing
the first thing students read is is
aeropagitica by john milton
which is about the importance of a free
press and it's about
um the fact that that in milton's time
to publish you had to be licensed
you know imagine a newspaper having to
seek a license from the government in
order to publish
and milton was saying this is wrong we
shouldn't have licensing
of of newspapers and saying why why the
free exchange of ideas is
is good for society it helps us reach
the truth is what
is is what he argues but then of course
there are always exceptions and there
are exceptions to the exceptions and
you get into these problems with
national security secrets and it seems
like we get into the more and more and
more as technology advances
and so on and so forth and i uh um
uh i have some opinions about snowden
and
and so but i think i think i think the
general rule needs to be what what what
president arne said
is we need uh people of good judgment uh
in government to know when to prosecute
when to not prosecute
and also people of good judgment in
journalism to know
when to print and when not to print and
we won't always get it right and there
will be hard choices to make
but we can be better or worse
based upon sound
i'd judgment to thank all of you guys
for coming out today and um and
providing your reaction
my question is going to go a lot back to
the dr arm conversation that happened
yesterday but i think it's very relevant
that we talk about this
so um in locke's second treatise of
civil government chapter 11 he talks
about this
non-delegation power the people can't
give power to the government that they
themselves don't have
so when we think about that i in the
state of nature cannot
censor the press however we see our
government does this all the time
my question to you and each of you is
where does that power of
press censorship come from how can we
work to restrain that back end
from a citizenry perspective thank you
i'll start with the observation um
i don't think the press is censored all
the time in fact i think certainly the
united states
the press is censored almost not at all
um
the the censorship if you want to call
it that
there may be some self-censorship you
know judgments about what belongs in
print and what doesn't belong in print
we have reasonable rules about libel
and slander and so forth but
it's very hard not to print almost
anything
in the united states and i've not read
john locke's second treatise in about 25
years so i'm not gonna
step into that step into that territory
this question might be for dr young
since you
said that you're not a big news junkie
or journalist
yourself but i felt like the speakers
gave
really good advice for journalists
like mr brookheiser and the four things
that journalists do
and mr hewitt's advice for journalists
but
what about those here that aren't trying
to be journalists themselves but
are just in trying to interpret the news
what do you think are the main points
that could be gathered from the speakers
in that term
well i think part of it is looking for
sources that embody those
characteristics that were mentioned
and i i really appreciated what john
said about
about the the literature focus and i
think that there's
something to be said for good writing in
in journalism
um but also just the the the character
aspect i mean i thought that that a lot
of what mr hewitt talked about was the
the rectitude the virtue
and so that's not maybe super easy to
identify but i think that's something to
look for some someone who's
writers who are thoughtful not only
smart but thoughtful
and seem to be people of virtue and i
think
to to be honest from my perspective you
can find
people like that with a variety of
political
persuasions
i'll jump in with a comment there what
you one one great thing you can do as
consumers of news
is is read all kinds of ideas including
ones you
disagree with i mean i write for
national review i think everybody should
read national review
when i read the wall street journal
editorial page i feel like i'm at home
in terms of in terms of uh political
opinion and so forth
but it's critically important to look at
what other people are saying and one of
the good
there's a bit of good news buried in
here because we all we're always hearing
so much about how
how partisan the united states has
become how we can
you know it's a 50 50 nation left right
we're talking past each other all the
time and things are a fair amount of
truth and all that
but if you if if you if you drill down
and look at some figures on how people
actually
how people actually interpret the news
how they get their news and so forth
conservatives are much more likely to
read
liberal opinion and liberals are much
more likely to read conservative opinion
then the great middle is likely to read
either
we see a good deal of curiosity on both
sides they want to know what other
people are thinking they want to engage
in ideas and i think that's a
that's a kind of hopeful sign and the
real problem in some ways we have a big
left right problem in america and we can
we can we can
talk about that for a long time but
there's another kind of problem which is
which is just a misinformation problem
an
apathy problem and people who don't care
about ideas
but i would encourage people to to to
read on the right and read on the left
and read on the
up and down and all over the spectrum
that
pete says doesn't exist and everywhere
well it's a it turns into a web instead
of a spectrum
it goes in a bunch of different
directions as opposed to as as opposed
to one continuum
but i think this is right this cannot be
un this cannot
you cannot overemphasize the importance
the way i put it is that is that if you
think about the people who you must
admire
as as thinkers who have things to say
they are the sorts of people always who
have learned from
stuff that they totally disagree with
that's how it works
um there are i'm in sociology i teach
sociology and
and there are studies they're
controversial it's it's unclear
how accurate the measurement is there
but there are studies
that everybody's talking about that do
suggest that there's
that it's becoming more common that
people who
um that people who consume opinion
good opinion journalism it's narrowing
and people
read less stuff that that
differs from their own point of view
than used to be the case especially
maybe
in what you're calling the middle um
no we don't we may not know for sure how
much
that's happening but enough people are
wondering
if it's happening and worrying about it
um all of us know
people who don't seem to pay much
attention
to things that they don't agree with at
least a few right
and i think it's i think whether or not
it's actually happening the fact that
we're becoming aware of it as an issue
is is absolutely critical um central to
being a liberally educated
person in the sense that hillsdale wants
you to be
is being the sort of person who has
learned from a
from a wide swath of um
of perspectives that encompass that that
that make up our tradition
um people who don't agree with each
other and yet who we consider
very much architects a part of our
tradition
um part of what part of what makes it so
difficult to be able for you students
to be able to look dr arne in the eye
when he sits down at your table
and in the dining hall and asks you what
is the good uh and and you'll seize up
and
and like i don't know and you feel like
you're supposed to know
um but part of the point of him asking
you of course is
is that it's important to get a hold on
how difficult it is
and how lifelong a struggle it is to try
to figure that out
that doesn't mean that you can't know
anything about it it doesn't mean that
you don't
move toward it but but i think it's
central
to moving toward it that's part of my
that's part of my point i think about
monsters
sometimes when we define monsters we
can't learn from them
and and it's clear that a lot of people
even when they
end up thinking that menken for example
is someone who
who has had influence that we don't like
in many ways
yet these same people are people who
have learned from him
who admire his writing and try to
understand what he's up to so
hi so along the same stream of thought
that we've been talking about just now
i'm curious about
bias in the last couple days it's
emerged that there seems to be an
interaction
between inform and
persuasion when it when it comes to the
purpose for journalism
so where would you say that the balance
lies there and
what is the appropriate interaction
between those two when it comes to
journalism and reporting
i think you want both i think any good
publication that seeks to
interpret the world fully is going to
have a news section and an editorial
section
i think the great newspapers all do that
um
so i think you want both and i think
sometimes it's hard to
you want you want you want opinion
sections that are actually have facts
and are evidence-based informative
um and in a news section i think you
want some pretty straight
objective news reporting on the one hand
on the other hand you want reporters
with a kind of sensibility to ask
certain kinds of questions and
and make sound judgments that'll help us
interpret the news so there's there's a
there's a kind of uh
there's a kind of uh a blending that can
take place but we can uh
we can make some real distinctions
between uh between news
and opinion
brookhaiser presented to us what i what
i found really striking
and compelling sort of situation in in
and the early american republic where
where he portrayed it i don't know for
sure that if this is overstated or not
but he portrayed this situation in which
everybody just kind of knew
that everybody's got a perspective
everybody knew that the different news
sources had a perspective and
those perspectives differed and at some
level people weren't worried about
everybody being objective and
my sense is my sense is that part of
what's striking about that
is that probably is a lot better way to
get towards something like objectivity
if we accept that
if we also if we also look at all the
perspectives
as opposed to limiting ourselves
we're actually returning to that model
in terms of journalism there's reason to
think
with with the diversity in the news
industry right now it's uh it looks
journalism today looks more like the
founding era than ever before
and the way it looked 50 years ago i
think we will never return to again the
notion that
there's a handful of news outlets
there's a sort of a false idea of
objectivity
um i think i think it's better now it's
not without
problems now without gigantic problems
but it's a better way to get information
now
i mean everybody kind of knows now that
in that era isn't it i'll ask john isn't
this right
and that that was the era when everybody
now knows there was an immense amount of
self-censorship
in the media in some areas especially
there were things that there were things
that were politely not reported
um and as we look as we look back where
that
that may have made sense in some ways
but we worry about that
james calendar would have had fun with
the kennedy white house oh yeah
if that's what you mean yes that's
that's one of the things i had in mind
yes
go ahead here
i think you finally hit the rich vein
here because this is the question i
wanted to pose
freddie siegel last night used the
expression just in response
to a question practice evidence-based
journalism
and that expression uh encompasses a lot
more than may appear at first because
that could cover both an opinion piece
and a so-called objective news report
the difficulty in my view is that
because
objective news reporting has been so
heavily sold
the public has come until
recently to rely almost entirely on the
news pages and ignored the editorial
pages in fact back when i was a
journalism student many years ago
they did readership surveys and found
out that the least read portion of the
newspaper was the editorial page
because after all that's merely opinion
and yet when a news reporter makes a
decision to report a story or integer
gives them that assignment
there's a judgment there and we all know
that and it goes all through it
so whether you're writing an opinion or
whether you're simply presenting
information
evidence is central to it and a
conclusion is always to be drawn from it
so i think if that that idea is taken to
heart
that can shall we say bless the whole
enterprise just like it should
yeah i second that i thought that was a
nice comment and and
i like that idea when you're when you're
writing something
which however you classify it addressing
the issue of
what makes you think that might be the
case any claim you make
backing up with evidence one of our
problems in relation to that
is not only whether people can capably
present
evidence it's also the the case that
again
it i think it's hard to be sure how much
effect this has
but i think it's the case that there are
many people in our society nowadays
whose whose cynicism has gotten deep
enough
that even if you present evidence well
there's a kind of a predisposition
to think that well you can't know or to
think that the evidence
that one person's source of evidence is
as good as anyone anyone else's
i i hope i'm sure this is probably the
case i'm hoping
that one of the things we're doing for
our students at hillsdale as well as
that
present evidence is that you can
consider
and be a consumer of evidence as well so
it's double edged
time for just one more question
i would like to ask dr blum when
thinking about the four types of
journalism that mr brookheiser talked
about
do you think that these four virtues
reveal anything significant or
unique about our society and how does
this compare to other societies around
the globe
my insofar as i have what could count as
expertise in sociology
it tends not to be in that area i can
give you impressions of
of of what i think sort of people
people would think in in
in sociology i think there are a lot of
people in sociology
who would who would be
in looking at cross-cultural comparisons
they
they probably would have a tendency to
discount as a sort of a value judgment
the the degree to which they're
discerning uh differences
that might be sort of authoritarian
differences sort of differences between
what we would call a free press
and and what elsewhere they would
consider um
they would consider sort of sort of a
press that's controlled by a government
there's only some there's only so much
that you can do to
ignore this kind of thing but i think
there is a kind of a tendency
sometimes to to believe that those sort
of judgments
that the press is or is not being
curtailed as sort of
value judgments um that that should be
sort of avoided or that one should be
really careful and deft with
when probably in fact they're just
judgments about what's really going on
um the the one of the things that
that i think i hope that the journalists
won't be
afraid to do is to make those kind of
judgments
in terms of those in terms of those
virtues what is part of what that means
is that those virtues are going to look
very different in different cultural
contexts
i think that they're going to be
contexts in which um in which
the virtues of journalism are going to
look
more like vices right um or they're
gonna look
they're at least gonna look like
something that needs to be curtailed and
kept
under wraps and one of the things that
one of the things that i think
for objectivity not just for freedom but
for objectivity
one of the things that we probably need
to do is cultivate the idea that seeing
those as virtues
is not just it's not just a value
judgment
like we think that but over there they
don't think that but
but to push the idea that there is
really something
about um about cultivating those virtues
that gives you and it gives you an edge
in really understanding what's going on
that it's not just a matter of differing
in value judgment
i hope that was coherent that was just
off the top of my head
does that does that sort of speak to
your question to some extent
as a as a non-expert opinion but but
sort of knowing what's going on in
sociology
all right thank you very much uh again
we'll be dismissed but feel free to come
up if you have questions afterwards and
speak to any of the panelists
thank you
you